nous retrouvons avec plaisir rebecca
makonnen pensons en patrimoine et du cac
et ça tombe bien parce que les vendredis
désormais c'est la journée où les
bagdadis sorte les nouveautés oui
harmoniser partout dans le monde la même
journée parce qu'avant ce n'était pas
tout le temps la même chose mission
c'était le mardi mais bon en australie
je pense que c'était le jeudi bref on
aurait vous retrouver tous les vendredis
inexactes et philippe brac
vous commencerez avec lui libre accès
nos tribulations en tout cas n'a
d'amuser catégorie chanson cette année
c'est un but qui est passé par beaucoup
de concurrents gagné plusieurs notamment
les francouvertes l'an dernier si son
deuxième album portrait de phan minh et
nom de famille oui un jeu de mots
s'était réalisé par louis jean cormier
mais moi ce que je préfère c'est quand
un artiste un pas de géant
entre le 1er et le 2ème album ça arrive
trop rarement selon moi mais c'est une
des choses que j'aime le plus parce que
l'artiste a vraiment évolué travaillais
pas je propose d'écouter si proche et si
loin à la fois un premier extrait je
vais pas descendre et justin
c'est une agent dément
et demain d'où la barbiche d'un cui de
sketches tomates et
ça
tessa bon le truc c'est que quand on
entre avec nous encore mis si on n'a pas
une identité
oui ça se bouge encore vous trouvez je
pense qu on entend sa signature mais y'a
pas le rouleau compresseur louis jean
cormier dans ce sens que tu les bras qui
avaient déjà une identité très défini
très solide
déjà très précises pour quand même un
jeune artiste que je pense qu'il y avait
éveillé vraiment son mot à dire
finalement c'est un gars qui peut être
touchant qui peut être à tignes et
parfois les gens qui ont peut-être
certains textes crus des bourgs et des
beaux moments de grâce avec des led un
quatuor à cordes
il ya des chutes tonitruante dans des
chansons vraiment la grosse [ __ ]
fausse je pense que c'est là aussi on
retrouve du louis jean cormier
c'est un duo avec l'opel gags et sur
scène patrice d'une redoutable les ans
vraiment le remarquable
vous nous direz quand il sera sur scène
vous avez beaucoup aimé son portrait de
famille et la sason intéresse à l egypte
boisjoli qui reprend des succès oui déjà
vous savez que moi je suis plus ou moins
tiède à l'idée d'aider des gens qui font
des albums hommages on en a un autre
l'année la semaine prochaine leurs
honoraires mario pelchat qui reprend je
pense de gilbert bécaud brigitte
boisjoli ex star académicienne qui nous
avait déjà faire un album très pop
deuxième album qui est sorti a pas très
longtemps qui était so et là apparemment
elle vraiment baigné dans la musique de
patikul annonce qu'elle était jeune sa
mère
il écoutait tout le temps on va écouter
la plus grande chanson la chanson la
plus connue
crazy
récit
après avoir fini
à
sauvé
bon bah oui c'est bon c'est quand j'en
entendu plus absolument c'est qu'en
vacances et léché c'est très bien fait
et la lll réussi à me faire croire que
le vraiment vécu cette peine donc c'est
une très bonne interprète
j'ai même j'ai même tendu leurs épices
mon cher et où jacques on vivait vous
mais j'ai tout le temps peur ou est ce
que l'accent anglais correct est ce
qu'on entendait mais le seul petit bémol
c'est que je sais pas si j'écoute
brigitte boisjoli qui chante patrick
langot brigitte boisjoli qui mitent
c'est l'idiot qui chante pas de cyclones
parce que le dé est le 6ème maniérisme
peu à la céline dion qui parfois peut
agacer ou genou sortir justement de
l'appréciation d'une chanson dans
l'ensemble vous avez été convaincu sur
une séquence but oui ça commence plutôt
bien sa main djs et puis ne changerai
pas je lis sur la feuille
john greenway il existe encore j'ai
envie d'en malheureusement je vais je
dois vous avouer je suis complètement
franchement non mais oh j'ai quand même
adore oui je sais mais j'ai quand même
adoré durden quand c'était vraiment plus
à la mode d'amis de cette quatorzième
album et je pense que c'est c'est comme
le le souffle désespéré d'un groupe
rentrait pas le faudrait que ça cesse il
quatorzième album
ils ont écouté avec l'énergie du
désespoir sont allés chercher tous les
gens qui sont super à la mode en ce
moment non rogers que travailler avec
daft punk mark ronson 4 avec bruno mars
amy winehouse je n'ai amené pour essayer
de retrouver l'étincelle et c'est
vraiment une astuce de drôles de
bouillie étrange c'est tellement mauvais
que c'est bon on va se quitter le people
god s'asseoir aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire en plus d'études papy je
comprends qu'aux en tout cas des
programmes pour les gens de votre
génération et des cas merci on les
écoute pas la semaine prochaine à paris
et